eu cresci ouvindo que o brasil era o
país do futuro que o brasil sem dúvida o
país promessa o país que faria tudo
acontecer era a grande esperança tanto
questões internas quando pensa ah o
brasil vai crescer mas é aquele país que
a economia vai dar certo que a sociedade
aberta é suficiente é um país que de
fato tem tudo para dar certo e também se
folha plano externo porque os outros
países e ana o brasil é aquele país que
vai fazer a diferença é que naquele jogo
de xadrez político o brasil seria um
país diferente e que conseguiria assumir
uma posição diferenciada uma talvez
terceira via algo mais solidário se for
considerar hoje dia 21 de outubro de
de fato esse futuro chegou afinal de
contas o brasil é uma das dez maiores
economias do mundo há anos já figura
nesse ranking o brasil é um país que é
levado muito a sério pelos outros países
do cenário internacional
pesos pesados é do das relações
internacionais como estados unidos
rússia alemanha a china leva o brasil a
sério querem chamar o brasil a discutir
situações importantes e problemas
globais
claro que esse futuro de chega com uma
série de contradições
sim somos uma das dez maiores economias
do mundo mas ao mesmo tempo também
estamos no topo dos rankings de países
mais desiguais no mundo
nós convivemos com violações de direitos
humanos graves que duram há décadas no
país
basta o nosso sistema prisional o nosso
próprio ministro da justiça já disse que
ele é medieval e não é uma situação nova
e pelo contrário cada ano que passa a
situação prisional no brasil ela se
torna cada vez mais irracional e
medieval ou mesmo se olharmos pelo outro
problema de direitos humanos que a
violência policial
nós deveríamos avançar caminhar para
frente
o que acontece é ainda hoje vemos
grandes resquícios da violência policial
inclusive resquícios da nossa ditadura
militar e o sistema de saúde nem
pergunta nem comentar né então passa
anos e anos a situação não melhora
mas independente de todas as
contradições incoerências que o brasil
apresente de fato ele ocupou um lugar no
mundo
não tem como negar que o brasil é hoje
um protagonista no âmbito internacional
e é por isso que o aproveitar a
oportunidade de hoje para discutir um
pouco com vocês como é o papel do brasil
no mundo e aí talvez quando vocês viram
o nome da palestra que eu tô dando hoje
ea idéia do projeto do papel do brasil
no mundo talvez alguns de vocês vão ter
pensado há mais uma pessoa falar sobre a
economia do brasil eo quanto as empresas
brasileiras estão se internacionalizando
ou mesmo pensar não mais uma pessoa para
falar sobre a quase obsessão do brasil
de ter um assento permanente no conselho
de direitos humanos e decidir as
questões de segurança e paz no mundo
na verdade vocês pensaram isso desculpa
mas eu não vou falar sobre isso eu na
realidade
optei quis assumir o desafio de falar de
um não-assunto taticamente no assunto
algo que se fala muito pouco que a
chamada política externa brasileira em
direitos humanos que no fundo é quais
são as ações e as posições que o brasil
adota diante das várias situações
horrorosas e temerosos que acontecem no
mundo em diferentes partes do globo e
com a posição que esse país promessa
esse país que era visto como o país do
futuro tenha assumido diante disso mas
antes de falar de brasil e falar sobre
qual a posição do brasil eu queria
perguntar cada um de vocês com que a sua
opinião afinal de contas eu tenho
certeza que cada um que está aqui
sentado hoje tem uma opinião sobre as
várias situações graves de violações de
direitos humanos que acontecem no mundo
hoje pegar por um exemplo o irã
fala se muito do irã ea situação das
mulheres no irã o irã até hoje ainda
aplica a pena de apedrejamento até a
morte de mulheres são acusados de um
crime de adultério adultério é crime no
irã
qual é a sua posição com relação a isso
isso deveria continuar os países
deveriam ficar calado sem respeitar uma
devida relativismo cultural ou não
deveria comunidade internacional da qual
nós também fazemos parte devemos atuar
em investir e atua com relação a isso
fim qual é a sua opinião com relação a
isso
outro caso que aconteceu há menos de
dois anos foi que o uganda o país
africano quis agora já no futuro aprovar
uma lei que criava a pena de morte para
gays
basta seguir o que você vai ser
condenado à pena de morte você vai ser
executado por sua orientação sexual
qual a sua opinião sobre isso o que a
comunidade internacional que os países
deveriam ter feito quando gana tentou
aprovar uma resolução uma lei que criava
a pena de morte para gays
ainda bem que essa razão essa legislação
ela não foi adotada e hoje por enquanto
ainda existem instituições que estão
mantendo é longe a criminalização da dos
homossexuais em uganda como vão pegar um
exemplo um pouco mais recente muito
próximo a nós no começo desse ano dois
brasileiros foram executados na
indonésia por conta de crimes de tráfico
de drogas tráfico de drogas não é um
crime hediondo e mesmo assim a indonésia
condenou executou dois brasileiros uma
série de outros nacionais de outros
países
o que você achou disso eram brasileiros
eram com patriota os nossos você
concordou com isso discordou
você acha que o brasil devia ter feito
mais directo feito - será que a onu
deveria ter invadido a indonésia nesse
caso eu pergunto qual a posição de vocês
que eu tenho certeza que cada um diante
de situações tão absurdas como essa têm
alguma posição
nós temos que lembrar que o brasil
também tem uma posição como o país e não
só tem uma posição uma opinião sobre o
tema mas defende atua no âmbito
internacional seja na onu seja
diretamente nas suas relações bilaterais
para impor a sua posição defender a sua
opinião e aí fica a dúvida será que a
opinião que cada um pense só aqui é a
mesma que o brasil defendeu
você sabe qual é a posição que o brasil
defendeu em casos como esse caso que já
aconteceram ou que ainda estão
acontecendo é por conta dessa ânsia de
se incômodo que eu sempre tive de o que
é que o meu país está dizendo lá fora
sobre situações que me incomodam tanto
me tocam como ser humano se essas
questões essas posições elas de alguma
forma conhecida em caminha
afinal de contas está sendo feito em meu
nome não só em meu nome mas no seu nome
do seu nome de nome de todos nós a
sociedade brasileira e é por isso que
desde há pelo menos dez anos eu trabalho
numa banda chamada conectas direitos
humanos que é uma ong que atua para
melhorar a situação dos direitos humanos
aqui no brasil mas também no mundo e
ajuda a melhorar a situação de direitos
humanos no mundo olhando pela
responsabilidade do nosso país
o brasil e copa do brasil tem adotado
diante de situações graves e violadores
de direitos humanos como essas que eu
mencionei nesses dez anos de trabalho
que eu tenho observado é que há uma
grande desinformação as pessoas e isso
inclui não sabem ou não sabemos qual é a
posição que o brasil tem adotado e
muitas vezes quando descubro isso me
choca me preocupa porque são posições
que eu não concordo e conversando com
amigos familiares ou meus alunos eles
também ficam surpresas
então a questão da desinformação me
preocupa muito nesse ponto
alguns exemplos de posições que talvez
sejam novas pra vocês ou não tomara que
não tomara que esteja já 19 o óbvio mas
falando do irão o caso que tinha
consultado você sabe qual é a sua
posição
o as nações unidas a onu adota cada ano
uma resolução que condena as violações
de direitos humanos no irã
são documentos discutidos entre os
países e que lhes estão as várias
violações de direitos humanos
perseguição a minorias religiosas
o tratamento desigual mulher à violência
contra a mulher
o uso abusivo da pena de morte todo ano
essa resolução discutida e votada na onu
o brasil é membro da onu que o brasil
tem que se posicionar com relação à
resolução
desde 2001 o brasil tem mantido uma
prática de se abster nessa resolução
ou seja o brasil nem vota a favor nem
vota contra se abstêm
ou seja fica em cima do muro o que você
acha disso é essa sua posição com
relação aos abusos que acontece no irã
em novembro agora vai ter uma nova
votação e o brasil provavelmente vai
saber ser de novo e meu nome em seu nome
e em nome de todo mundo
um outro exemplo a coreia do norte um
dos regimes mais fechados que existem no
mundo
um regime tão brutal e totalitário que
inclusive controla quais países podem
ter embaixada lá
hoje nós temos mais de 200 países no
mundo apenas 24 países têm autorização
do governo norte coreano para ter uma
embaixada um desses 24 países escolhidos
o brasil é um deles desde 2009 nosso
estado com os nossos impostos mantenham
embaixada em pyongyang capital da coreia
do norte
vocês concordam com isso sabiam disso o
que será que o nosso embaixador em que a
união faz dia após dia
afinal de contas ter uma embaixada tem
um acesso privilegiado ao que acontece
no terreno é poder ver sem ter que ler
relatórios sem ter que ouvir relatos é
poder vivenciar o dia a dia de um dos
regimes mais fechados e mais violadores
de direitos humanos o estado brasileiro
país brasil tem esse privilégio porque
tem uma embaixada lá e aí que será que
nosso embaixador faz todos os dias
um outro exemplo é a crise humanitária
na síria ea crise dos refugiados nós
ficamos todos muito chocados e
horrorizados com as imagens na europa ea
forma como essas pessoas elas estão
sendo tratados por ano já que a guerra
já dura há muitos anos e como os outros
pais têm fechado suas portas para
acolhê-los
o brasil não sei se vocês sabem mas é um
país que tem recebido mais refugiados
sírios do que os estados unidos por
exemplo a grande potência econômica e
militar
enfim a que se diz a grande democracia
no mundo é algo que vocês concordam com
essa posição solidária é a minha posição
sim eu acredito que o brasil se está
fazendo muito certo por isso a grande
preocupação é com relação à qual é o
grau de desinformação isso porque no
fundo essas ações elas são feitas e como
mencionei antes em nome da sociedade
brasileira ea grande preocupação é que
política externa é uma política pública
se estamos numa democracia não faz
sentido nós não temos essas informações
sobre o que o brasil tem feito lá fora
em termos de direitos humanos eu disse
alguns exemplos mas são vários outros
exemplos que poderia ter falado aqui de
situações abusivas que acontecem no
mundo e que o brasil não poderia ficar
lá
esse objetivo e é por isso que eu tenho
insistido muito
que política externa é uma política
pública o que significa que você ter
acesso à informação nós precisamos saber
mas não é que nós temos que ser curiosos
e perguntarmos na o estado brasileiro
tem que oferecer essa informação e deve
nos ouvir
deve inclusive abrir canais para receber
contribuições insumos nossos wii
thamarat que o nosso ministério de
relações exteriores anunciou que vai
lançar o livro branco da política
externa é um instrumento muito positivo
porque é um documento que colocaria no
papel quais são os princípios as
estratégias dos objetivos do brasil na
sua ação internacional inclusive em
direitos humanos
essa promessa era de que esse livro
branco seria publicado até o final de
até hoje até o futuro de hoje nada
aconteceu não tem livro branco
então faça um convite a todos nós aqui
para cobrarmos das instituições de
governo que esse livro branco exista
pelo menos conhecemos com a posição mas
não só que ele seja feito mas que também
lhe seja feito a partir de uma consulta
ampla a todos nós somos parte da
sociedade brasileira porque no fundo
quando o brasil defende uma posição ou
outra diante do abuso de direitos
humanos no mundo ou pior quando decide
ficar em cima do muro e está fazendo em
nosso nome
então no meu pedido é vamos cobrar e
entender qual é essa postura que o
brasil tem defendido
afinal de contas a gente precisa
primeiro saber qual é porque caso ela
não conhecida com a nossa casa não
concordemos com essa posição aí sim nós
temos uma outra tarefa que é questionar
e tentar mudar muito obrigado